now that apple has refreshed their 2025k
imac with absolutely killer specs and
features
a lot of you guys are upgrading so we
created a buyer's guide video to help
you figure out which model
and which upgrades you should buy but
one of the biggest dilemmas
is how much ram you should buy now this
video is gonna apply to every medium to
higher end mac
like the higher-end 13-inch macbook pro
which can be configured up to 32 gigs of
ram
the 16-inch macbook pro with 64 the mac
mini
the 5k imac and even the mac pro
now the great thing about the 2025k imac
is that we still have
an access door for upgrading the ram
ourselves
and ram is much less expensive than it
was last year
for example 32 gigabytes used to be a
hundred and seventy one dollars
now it's only a hundred and twenty and
128 gigs
used to cost eleven hundred dollars and
now it's only
500 bucks so what we're gonna do in this
video is run
actual benchmarks in real world tests
like photo editing using lightroom
classic
video editing using final cut pro 10
gaming performance
logic pro music production and i'll even
discuss
programming using xcode we're going to
be comparing the factory 8 gigs that
comes with the imac
then 16 gigs for 70 on amazon
32 gigabytes for a hundred and twenty
dollars
and 64 gigs for 250 dollars
and by the way we'll have links to all
of these ram deals
down in the description below now i do
want to mention that we're actually not
going to be testing 128 gigs
because we tested 64 gigs and realized
that even that was overkill
for a lot of these tests so you really
only want to get 128 gigs
if you want to show off to your friends
or maybe if you're running virtual
machines now before we begin
here are the specs of our test machine
the 2300
2025k imac which we think is a very
solid option for a lot of people
as you guys know if you watched our
recent review video now before we get
into our testing
if this video ends up helping you out
make sure to go down below into our
merch shelf and check out our all over
apple product design
and our new apple product mask and i do
want to mention that we ran
all of these tests with 10 chrome tabs
open in the background
which is a good realistic limit to give
a little bit of extra wiggle room
just in case you like to browse the web
while doing your work like i personally
do
let's go ahead and start off our testing
with geekbench 5's
cpu test which actually does get
affected by ram
since the test happens in short bursts
unlike a real world scenario
going from 8 gigabytes of ram to 64 the
single core score does go up by around
28 points which honestly isn't that much
but wait until you see the multi-core
score here
we see a massive gain of 1 617
points going from 8 gigs to 64 gigabytes
of ram
or a 22 improvement in this benchmark
and there really wasn't that big of a
jump between 32 and 64.
so 32 gigs of ram seems to be pretty
solid so far
and it was even more interesting that
just by going from 8 gigs to sixteen
gave us a huge improvement almost a
thousand points higher
now let's get right into our lightroom
classic photo editing tests
which greatly depend on ram so we should
see some pretty interesting results here
exporting 500 raw 42 megapixel photos
there was a massive improvement going
from 8 gigs of ram
to 64 being almost twice as fast
which is a huge surprise since all we
did was change the ram
and it's still on the same 8 core system
and by simply going from 8 to 16 gigs
saves you over 10 minutes on the export
not bad for an extra 70 dollars if
you're buying the ram
straight from amazon instead of paying
apple two hundred dollars for it on
their website
now moving on to building one-to-one
previews of 50 raw 42 megapixel photos
our results are actually a little bit
different just like the export test
we finished almost twice as fast by
having 64 gigs of ram
compared to the factory 8 gigs and again
just like the other test going from 8 to
16
saves you over a full minute so this
shows that even for users who are
looking to buy a 13-inch macbook pro
definitely get at least 16 gigs if
you're photo editing
or you're doing graphic design work like
in photoshop or
other apps like that and it's even worth
going up to 32 gigs
if you're doing it all the time however
going from 32 gigs to 64
only saved us three seconds when
building the previews
which isn't nearly as big of an
improvement as for
the export test now moving on to our
gaming test
we ran unigine's heaven benchmark while
having 10 chrome tabs open
and to our surprise we got basically the
same score
no matter how much ram we had even with
only 8 gigs of ram
which was surprising linus tech tips
actually did a great video on this
testing three different games and they
found that going from 8 gigs
to 16 gave them a much smoother gaming
experience
but going from 16 to 32 didn't really
change much at all
so you should definitely watch that
video if you want to learn more one
benefit with the imac is that you can
buy some ram
and add it to the existing 8 gigs of ram
that's in the system already
so if you buy a 16 gig kit for only 70
on amazon you can fill the empty slots
and have 24 gigs total
just to be safe or of course you can get
a 32 gig kit
and end up with 40 gigs of ram total
however
if you simply fill in the empty slots
your ram speed will actually down clock
from 2.6 gigahertz to 2.1 gigahertz
so 925 mac found a great trick on how to
get around this
you basically take the bottom stick from
the existing ram
and move it to the top slot so you
should have the top two slots filled
and then putting your two new sticks on
the bottom and you should end up with
all of your ram
running at the highest speed as you can
see in 95 max video
now moving on to music production using
logic pro 10
our viewer joe swainson pointed us to
the new logic benchmark 2 project
created by martin ray which basically
has you run
as many instrument tracks as possible
before you get a system overload message
in this test we were surprised to see
that logic was only taking
a couple of gigabytes of memory and
going from 8 to 64 gigs
only helped our system run 5 extra
tracks at once
before overloading so it seems like at
least for this test
ram isn't that big of a factor for logic
pro 10
and we recommend at least 16 gigs unless
you know your workload will require more
ram
due to using more plug-ins or things
like that now finally getting into video
editing with final cut pro 10
we exported our standard 5 minute 4k
clip
with two luts and film grain added which
is basically the most common format
and workload that most youtubers use
going from 8 gigabytes to 64
we saved about a minute and 20 seconds
on our
export which shows that final cut was
definitely being limited
by only having eight gigs of ram and
over time
you'll definitely notice that difference
and even going to 32 gigs helped out
quite a bit for exporting this 5 minute
4k
clip saving us 26 seconds in this test
but going from 32 to 64 didn't really do
much at all
only saving us 4 seconds so we can
definitely see the diminishing returns
here
now we also ran our 5 minute canon c200
60p raw export which is definitely a
more difficult test
and here we saved 2 minutes and 20
seconds
by going from 8 gigs to 64 gigs of ram
which honestly isn't as big of a
difference as i was expecting
we definitely saw a decent improvement
going up to 32 gigs of ram
but going to 64 gigs only gave us a 15
second
improvement which isn't that much at all
considering the total time it took to
export the raw clip
now before we get into the conclusions
there's just one more test
we basically ran the lightroom export
test while having the 5 minute 4k
project open
in final cut pro it was interesting to
see that most of the results were
identical compared to not having final
cut pro open
which means that mac os is doing a very
good job with page
filing basically offloading final cut
pro
from the ram onto the ssd to give
more ram to lightroom classic so that's
a very good sign
however with only eight gigabytes of ram
our export was slower by around
50 seconds which means that even page
filing
couldn't help with ram that low so now
with all of that testing complete
let's go through our recommendations
eight gigabytes
is simply not enough even for basic web
browsing with chrome
it suffered greatly in basically every
single test
taking almost twice as long for video
editing
and for photo editing now if you're a
gamer you'll want at least
16 gigabytes of ram for a smooth gaming
experience
potentially keeping the existing eight
gigs so you have some extra wiggle room
for discord and you should probably go
up to 32 gigabytes
if you want to do some live game
streaming but you honestly don't need
any more than that now for logic pro 10
users
we were surprised to see that ram didn't
really have that big of an effect
so 16 gigs should be enough or 32
if you're running various plugins but 64
gigabytes is probably already overkill
for video editing using final cut pro 10
it seems like 32 gigs is honestly the
sweet spot
so you can buy a 32 gig kit for 120
dollars
and then in the future you can add
another 32 gigs
if you feel like it's not enough but
honestly
we don't think going for 64 gigs is
worth it for video editing
and that applies to all macs including
the 16-inch macbook pro
now for photo editing using lightroom
classic or other graphics design
work like photoshop or anything like
that you'll definitely want at least
32 gigabytes for a smooth editing
experience
and fast export times going up to 64
gigs didn't really help with building
previews
but it did save a couple of minutes on
our export test
so to some people who believe that time
is money
paying an extra 130 for 64 gigs of ram
would probably be worth it in this case
and then later
if you really want to you can add
another 64 gigs for a total of 128
if you ever feel like you want to try
and squeeze a little bit more
performance out of your mac
or if you just want to show off to your
friends so based on that conclusion
i think users who use xcode for
programming
will probably have a great experience
with 32 gigs of ram
and possibly a little bit of extra gains
with 64 gigs
which could be worth the extra 130
dollars
to some people but not to everyone and
by the way
we're actually working with one of our
viewers to get an xcode benchmark
working so subscribe if you want to see
that and there you guys go
hopefully this video helps you finally
figure out how much ram
you need for your mac no matter which
mac you have
so if this video helps you out go ahead
and use the ram links below
to find the best deals on 5k imac
and mac pro ram and go ahead and click
that circle above to subscribe
and be sure to check out our apple
product merch like our all over apple
product premium t-shirt
or our new apple product mask thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one